للمره الثانيه على التوالي وفي غضون شهرين
فقط يتسبب سقوطه مياه الامطار بكميات
كبيره بغرق اغلب احياء وشوارع العاصمه
بغداد الامر الذي ادى الى شلل شبهتا من
للحركه فيها عطيه
ما نقدر كل شيء يشتغل واحنا ناس على باب
الله
الذي استمر اكثر من اثني عشر ساعه تسبب
انقطاع التيار الكهربائي وسقوطها عميله
الكهرباء والاشجار في الطرقات الامر الذي
ادى الى تعطي للدوامي في الجامعات
والمعاهد والله من البارحه لو اجتنا
البلديه لا سونا حل هذه الماء يعني احنا
اليوم ما قدرنا نطلع للشغل
غرقه
وتاذى بلكه الله الدوله يعني الدير بالهم
عليهم تعوضهم تعطيهم شيء يعني خطيه طلعوا
من بيوتهم رغم السنفار يا مانك بغداد
لكافه كوادرها الفنيه الا انها لم تتمكن
الى الان من سحب مياه الامطار من احياء
بغداد لتستعين باليات وزارتي الدفاعي
والداخليه التي تعمل منذ ساعات للمساهمه
في تصريف مياه الامطار التي سقطت بكميات
كبيره والتي تحولت الى سيولن في المدن
والبلدات الحدوديه مع ايران من بغداد
منتظر رشيد العربيه